au vélodrome nationale les équipes sont
dans les starting blocks pour vous faire
passer des vacances sportives
les saint quentinois auront accès
gratuitement aux activités cyclistes
vous allez avoir des parcours vtt avec
des initiations du côté de lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
vous avez également toute la partie
baptême bmx session et initiation on est
en train de valider la possibilité
d'installer une petite piste de paume
trac pour des mini ride et pour les plus
petits l'été sera aussi sportif à lille
de loisirs l'accrobranche ou le beach
volley sont bien sûr proposé pour son
village estivale du 15 juillet au 14
août le site vous réservent de nouvelles
découvertes non par exemple du coccyx
bola donc le principe c'est de ces de
lancer une balle avec en tirant sur un
sur un tissu on a dû de l'archerie tags
donc on se tire dessus avec des arcs et
des flèches avec thébaux en mousse donc
en toute sécurité
évidemment et tous les jours on a une
dizaine ou une quinzaine d'animateurs
qui vont être là et on est en
partenariat avec tout le mouvement
sportif sportif local et départemental
après tous ces efforts l'île de loisirs
proposera un parcours fraîcheur à partir
du 22 juillet plus de raison de ne pas
tester une nouvelle activité